four three seven
four one
and lemon
you're listening to the dollop on the
all things comedy network this is a
bilingual american history podcast where
each week i david antonio read a story
from american history
me amigo gareth reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about
there's some notes on the uh
maybe with the notes the new dave
anthony c
well uh i don't think you speak enough
spanish to do this megusta basketball
i don't know a lot but that's not right
huh yeah no donde esta bibliotec
there's a few of them you need to go
we're recording a podcast see
yes i don't think it's a good time to go
to the library donde esta
la bibliotec
you can find it but you can't go there
now we need to do
don't they
that uh
left if you go left you'll run into it
the [ __ ] christmas no no
uh oh i shoulda
well i guess i'll do that later do it
later
i've got to bring up the uh
that
on my thingamadoodle okay
um because i had to update my computer
and an i'm
time and the
files wouldn't translate over
and it's not interesting
dave come on it's not interesting but go
to something interesting then do your
[ __ ] all right hi everybody hey
australia whoopsies all right let's move
on domestically uh i will be at the
spokane comedy club thursday august 26
at 8 p.m then the following evening i'll
be at the tacoma comedy club friday and
saturday uh and there's a couple shows
there uh so you can go to my website
gareth.com for information there also
i'm excited to announce i'll be going
home to milwaukee wisconsin for the
milwaukee improv friday september 3rd
saturday september 4th the milwaukee
improv and then i'll be at the stress
factory in new jersey
september 10th through the 11th uh and
then we the dollop will be uh at the
high plains comedy fest in denver
colorado that is september 18th we have
a show um you and then i will be at the
stress factory in bridgeport friday
october 1st saturday october 2nd you can
go to gareth reynolds.com for all that
information
uh ticket information and then dave we
are also hitting some places
yes we are to make your nipples hard my
nips are hard
14th wiseguys las vegas september 16th
wise guys salt lake city hey i bet
that's a uh quite a bit we go from major
major sin to
uh let's wear underpants that are
special so we go to heaven it's gonna be
fun that's that that's uh tuesday this
is 14th wise guys las vegas thursday
september 16th wise guys salt lake city
like i said high plains comedy festival
the 18th of september and then wednesday
september 22nd we will be at stand up
live in phoenix november 5th we will be
at the palace of the fine arts in san
francisco november 6 will be at the
crest theater in sacramento and december
10th will be at the observatory north
park san diego
girl all those shows vaccinated yes uh i
believe you can also get a test if you
uh i think that's what we came down with
right yep you get a test you can go in
or you can be be vaccinated or have a
negative covert test and you can go to
dolloppodcast.com for information on
those and some people call those nazis
and this is a history podcast so i'd
like you to actually look up what nazis
are since you're listening to a history
podcast ah welcome to america a nazi is
your enemy no matter what your enemy
thinks
we're brought to you in part by a zip
recruiter look according to uh forbes
gyms nail salons hotels mama pop stars
and more are about to go on a huge
hiring spree in the next coming months
to meet the pent-up demand for services
sure i personally movie theaters would
very very much like to get back into
movie theaters very excited about that
and concerts like i really miss going to
concerts well you should go see the
dollop
yes
uh so look all these businesses are
gonna be reopening that means millions
jobs are gonna need to be filled so
where do these businesses turn to fill
their roles fast that's right gareth zip
recruiter i'm glad you said it and right
now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com dollop what are we
going to say
as a zip recruiter
look when you post a job on zippercutter
they send your job to over 100 top job
sites giving you access to their network
of millions of job seekers
uh you can easily review recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply come on apply you say
now for your job you go hi apply would
you like to be a cat lifter which
encourages them to apply
faster
and zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zipper crew to get
a quality candidate within the first day
you can find a cat heavy cap guy i'm not
looking for that sorry you're looking
for a seal person now or hiring and
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com.ziprecritter.com
d-o-l-l-o-p just go to ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter the smartest way
too higher yes and that's what we're
into hiring we're big
big big big hiring yeah we're on a we're
on the we love hiring yeah we've always
loved hiring i'd love to get hired uh
let's face it uh shopping for a car or
home insurance it's complicated sure it
is complicated
you can spend days looking up hundreds
of providers just going through and
scrolling through thousands of policy
options it can really be a total
nightmare i've done this with uh home
car especially i it just
it's tedious it's a nightmare and then
you get spam and robo calls from the
people and oh so that's cool yeah it's
uh you see that something to remember
him but
it's not great uh so
it's hard to know if you're getting the
best price and coverage for your
particular needs and that's where the
zebra can help you yeah that's where the
zebra comes in
is how long a zebra no the zebra is the
nation's leading insurance comparison
site for car and home insurance in other
words they do the shopping for you in
just five minutes you can compare quotes
from every major insurance provider side
by side for free
all from one independent marketplace
zebra pairs people with the insurance
company that's right for them delivering
quotes
with the coverage they need and saving
them an average of 922 on home and car
insurance combined wow how about that
there we go
wouldn't be the sound associated with
the company that's the zebra shop car
insurance without shopping around get
all your options in one place for free
by visiting the zebra.com
dollop that's the zebra.com
slash a dollop there it is
where the magic happens yes
we are also of course brought to you by
well i just say the people that i i i
consider myself sleeping with them
uh of course i am talking about helix
we sleep we sleep with healers or yes we
do we are sleeping with them uh i i we
both have helix mattresses i have the
dusk lux
uh really really nice mattress i course
sleep on my eyebrows
and uh the mattresses made they have
mattresses made for how you sleep and uh
i sleep like a baby yeah right eyebrows
there's not a lot right uh they're very
good but i don't know about the
necessarily that position very detailed
i would be surprised if they condone the
heavier sleepers too
uh so i've had my helix sleep my helix
mattress for a little while and it comes
in in a box and it opens up and it
screams and it hops around yeah it's a
magical guy it's like having eyes on it
yes it has it's like having a baby yes
i can think of a few differences
honestly yeah yeah uh it doesn't go to
the bathroom no not yet helix uh so what
you do is helix sleep has a quiz it
takes two minutes to do it matches your
body type your sleep preferences with
the mattress that you want you're
getting a mattress catered to you that's
right and
everybody's unique and helix knows that
they know how if you're going to sleep
on your eyebrows or whatever yeah so
then they're like don't be a part of
this business so they're like they have
several mattresses models that you can
choose from yeah soft medium firm that
whole deal cooling you know you're hot
you're not hot however you like to do it
so i took the quiz i was matched like i
said with the the dusk lux and uh it's
great it's it's a medium medium little
guy and uh i sleep i sleep comfortably
right on the old face
so look if you're looking for
if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door
ship for free and you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again that's it
it's awesome uh you just go to
helixsleep.com take the two minute quiz
and they'll match you with the
customized mattress that will give you
the best
sleep of your
life
um they've got uh tons of uh
big uh mattress picks by the big
companies gq and wired magazine uh
chiropractors are recommending them so
it's yeah 10 year warranty you can try
it out for free for 100 nights risk free
helix is offering up to 200
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
dollop
200 off get involved get involved get
your pillow on
is that what they say no it is now
all right you got anything else i'm
tired of you
what a negative let's get going it's
called chemistry
that's not how it works we're supposed
to be connecting right now
what's your problem
oh god
january 6 1799
year of our lord
was every year the lord of jesus every
single one is the year do we need to say
it then all years of the years do we
need to say that would be my question
well yeah because we this is a christian
podcast right
yeah we need to talk off air later about
a couple of things i forgot to do the
music oh great
so what does that mean we don't do it
this is not gonna do music this week
okay
what a rogue call this the whole thing's
in shambles yeah this is a nightmare
this isn't the maybe we are a christian
is it a shambles or in shambles it would
be in shambles
shambles it's not a shambles it's not a
shambles no shambles is a clown so if
it's a shambles it's the clown and you
don't want shambles coming to your party
he's not good i got us a bunch of
receipts ma'am uh don't worry i'll talk
the hard on before the party i'm gonna
look at you on the screen over here and
set it directly at you great much better
for me have you seen 100 foot wave on
hbo why don't we start have you seen it
let's go january 6 1799 [ __ ] awesome
great
january 6 1799 jedediah strong smith was
born
smith yeah i mean look name him as dumb
as you can i've already said that
strong smith well he's going to be very
religious and very strong if you need
your strong fix to go to jebediah
one of those babies that are born with
muscles have you ever seen those babies
yeah there's that russian kid who's i've
got my eye on him i haven't seen him
since he was eight there was a german
kid when we were young too that was like
all buffed and crazy
i mean really that i feel like the
authorities should just really be on
watch and that's like to be like it's
genetic it's like what are you forcing
him to do
move in move in on it yeah exactly we'd
start testing yeah exactly get him in
the lab all right now it's time for 45
000 push-ups before oatmeal that's right
uh so jedidiah was born in new york
state and a little while after that they
moved to erie pennsylvania as you do
and then to ashtabula
yeah all right but fair enough um
parents crank out their uh 13 kids all
together there you go keep it moving
there's a line back here keep it moving
up front that's a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of babies um like a conveyor belt
yeah
a neighbor took interest in general are
newborns pregnant well that seems
strange they're coming out like that now
we've done such a good job oh boy
uh so a neighbor takes interest in him i
don't know what that means a neighbor
takes interest in jeddah yeah he's like
i was an interesting boy uh-huh okay you
guys have a conversation yeah not you
can't do that now and todd i'd like to
have dinner with you soon
he taught him the quote
uh
resumes of an english education and
smattering of latin okay so he taught
him so jedediah was just going to go
through life uneducated and then this
guy was like you should be able to read
yeah
what if you're not a dummy right yeah
okay
so this neighbor probably gave jedediah
his prized copy of the journals of lewis
and clark okay so we've never covered
lewis and clark which we probably will
at some point but it's very famous story
but you know the guys who went across
first basically yeah well uh the
white guys
really
they were like boy
so lucky that there's another hot fire
here
we really are doing well
uh so this got him really interested in
exploring the american west okay now
when he's 13 he got a job as a clerk on
a great lakes freighter sure so he's
working at 13 as you do yep um he did
that it used to be weird
very good very conditioned doing that
we're going to get back why do you start
so late yeah that's what i say at 23 he
moves to st louis sure yeah what
go-karts
yeah go go-karts what's happening right
now he loves the go-karts there oh in st
louis yes they're aaron's favorite aaron
likes the go-karts in st louis he loves
riding him
um so
a jedi writes that his life goals were
to quote become a first-rate hunter make
myself thoroughly acquainted with the
indians trace out the sources of the
columbia river and make the whole
profitable to me well the last one is
why we're hearing about it obviously
because because it is a sweet list to
start off with
and then at the end it's like sign
jeffrey bezos uh so here's what i want
to do i want to share i want to be a
really good hunter great that's
important i want to meet the people that
live out there you know not the people
that have lived there
not now let me tell you this because i
love it not enough people are doing that
because what we find a lot of times here
is that people really have no interest
in the culture
and
the white and the white the white man
has been really uh unfair i think in
ways that they've sort of taken and not
learned i think there's
so much to learn so i think that's a
great instinct for you yeah hunt to to
meet get to know the people yeah people
find out the source of the columbia
river where does it come from where does
the columbia river
we actually were just talking about that
the other day we were trying to figure
out right well i mean it's helpful to
know that current wise that's going to
be you know for as far as beaver
trapping and things of that nature
and i guess the fourth one is
i want to make some money
okay so that you first of all it is what
turn it into cash it's 8 a.m meeting
those are meeting those uh native
americans how do i turn that into
[ __ ] money no no no finding out where
the columbia river starts how do i turn
that into money hunting we know how to
turn that into money no no no no every
goddamn thing on that beaver you're
probably every single thing on that b
roman it's all the the pelts stop
talking
the eyeballs the fingernails they don't
that little tail thing that's a tail
sell it money money money money money
all right okay
i'm going to bring a guy in cash there's
a lot of blood coming out of your ears
very excited the hell's happening a
prophet oh my god
in february 18 22 great to meet you oh
nice to meet you
how can i turn this into money this
meeting
william h actually sought a 100 quote
young men of enterprise to ascend the
missouri river to its source okay this
is right up our boy's alley yeah
uh it's it would take three years going
west through what is now kansas and then
up through the dakotas and montana
[ __ ] it's gonna take oh yeah not
really years what about what here here's
what i when i hear that and if i'm
around that time i'm thinking what about
me sitting on a porch with a rocking
chair well the truth is it's that we're
like it's just impossible to wrap your
mind around that concept because if you
were to put three years into something
now the immediate benefit you would have
to be guaranteed in order to invest yeah
but they were just like there's nothing
going on it's like we're gonna find out
where this river starts
okay yeah it's life
that okay that ought to be our lives
for a while that'll be a wrap and put
some years in i think that could take
three to fifteen years but it'll be
worth it we literally have [ __ ] all else
to do okay it's either that or just die
eating [ __ ] and die
i'm kind of leaning towards the dying
i'm not hating that pitch neither it's
not that bad all right well then we
won't look for it we'll sit here and
we'll just eat and we'll just die i'm
fine with it i'm gonna bring in the
yellow fever great that's great i've
always wanted to die for something along
those lines hey boys can we get the
yellow fever in here we got a bunch of
it coming down in buckets okay let's do
this that's how favors work
so that's bringing jedediah heads up
river on the keel boat enterprise
captain's log well connected to another
captain's log i think vanderbilt
fourth captain's log followed by fifth
captain a fifth titan captain's logs
this whole vessel is captain's logs okay
three weeks in it sank oh that's pretty
good that's a good round that's pretty
good it's a good run that's pretty good
that's better than most of the voyages
we hear here so they're stuck there they
got a hunt and forage while they're
waiting for a replacement boat to come
sure
replacement boat comes in october they
make it to
fort henry in southeast montana okay
major
ander henry was in charge of fort henry
okay so you see how yeah it's just like
when you discover
yeah the better that's
this is better than discovering you're
building something and you go i'm going
to name this after after me yes because
i'm pretty yeah i'm pretty [ __ ] rad
well it's like i mean really white's
just hgtv the country right they just
went everywhere and they were like oh
this needs to be a
mall
st louis let's put up some go-karts
that's what we'll be known for in this
town and nothing more
stupid little cars with bumpers racing
each other with stupid helmets while
tires buffer around the rink i don't
think they're stupid they're dumb okay
so jedediah heads up north of the forked
trap he's very generally he's very
religious as we guess from his name sure
um he always carried a bible and he sang
gospel songs while writing through the
what a terrible partner what a dream
what a dream partner yeah did nothing
but may the lord have blessed us once
again and now we're singing our sin the
lord hath blessed us bless this land can
we sing any and something else
lord hath blessed us
i just uh well i'd like to let's sing a
song about it i don't know about
tributaries but the lord dark work in
mysterious ways oh lord bless this land
can we do a song oh bless this land not
about the lord lord came down one day
said boys this guy's my baby he jesus
christ that was the way he was in two
that's the way we're gonna live a la la
la
one in the fate
and two in the hands can i ask you a
question yeah you've been singing these
religious songs for 400 [ __ ] miles
yeah have you ever thought about
shutting your goddamn
god hole i'll tell you what i had
thought about though
well the grass came down from the sky
same with the rain if you think about
that
uh like what if you were an atheist
i cannot imagine being an atheist at
this time just what a nightmare was oh
my god actually like i mean it's even
tough now to like pose questions yeah
back then you were like i mean do you
really think yeah what if there's no
there's no garden of no garden
uh so jedi is a methodist sure he
doesn't smoke he doesn't swear he
doesn't [ __ ]
um
unlike other mountain men he was clean
shaven and he bathed regularly he used
soap jamie didn't [ __ ] so he's like the
most well-groomed man of the time and he
won't [ __ ]
the only guy you'd really want to [ __ ]
he's got no beard and he's bathed yeah
it's really cool unfortunately i just do
that for passage to heaven
his fellow trappers called him bible
toter or old jet sure
local natives uh at some point stole
about 50 of major henry's horses okay so
without horses the trappers can't move
very far from the fort
hence probably why they stole them right
right
so general ashley is at this point he's
on his way from st louis
so jedediah is sent to meet him on a
canoe down the river
and tell him to get more horses from the
sioux
or any other people around if you can
when you're coming up um so he meets up
with ashley in may of 1823
and uh so actually stops and barters
with the uh i'm going to say this now
erica
for horses okay
and um
they had built a timber structure
on a sandbar in the river perfect to
block boats from going up so that's it
so it's a red flag situation if you like
if you're if you're say a white guy on a
big boat now you this big wall here is a
bit of a bother how am i going to
coordinate around that it's a bit tough
isn't it excuse me
open the door or whatever
so uh it's like indiana jones [ __ ] it's
just so dumb like well they seem
friendly except for this giant pile of
[ __ ] in our way
it's almost like they put it there on
purpose ah doesn't it
so uh actually exchanges gifts and then
buys 19 horses from them and 200 buffalo
robes
right okay
and then uh
thick rope
uh
ropes right
rope buffalo ropes robe robe robe better
yeah oh yeah um way better yeah although
buffalo rub seems like it would be cool
yeah buffalo rub would be great i hope
someone made buffalo i mean something
there was a lot of buffalo that would be
great if somebody could make [ __ ] out of
yeah for sure yeah there's a lot that
are laying around that would be really
important
so they type they tied the horses the
way they tie up horses back then is they
would tie their legs together awesome
and so they wouldn't run away so it's
like a three-legged race it's a
three-legged horse situation okay so
they have would they put them in sacks
and make them carry an egg on a spoon oh
my god i would pay to watch that
so that's how they kept horses running
away so they have all the horses lined
up on the riverbank and then they go to
sleep on the boats or the or the on the
keel boat or the riverbank and they're
gonna leave the next morning okay but it
turns out the uh uh the uh i'm gonna say
it raw again are you cara they again are
like boy more horses but turns out
they've been screwed over by white guys
before
and they're not really interested in
having white people around
so 600 attacked that night oh okay and
uh dave as far as battles go that's a
big number that's a large number it
sounds like a lot for a sleep attack
well actually has 40 guys oh okay less
so no hold on a second
we got a pen and paper here you're not
good at math no no no but that's close
it seems like a dominating force it's
much more than
40 40. okay 600 and the 40 are sleeping
yeah okay
uh 12 died i mean you literally could
just be like we're just going to put 10
uh on each person and just beat the [ __ ]
up
that's our plan that's it
so 12 die and 11 are wounded okay um
and the next morning ashley orders his
party
to try advancing up the river again
smart please otherwise
hey boys
let's get up there the problem is we
haven't made it
perhaps you didn't hear me when we
started from st louis but this is about
money yeah so
we got to get up there even if all you
have to die okay
everybody refused to go
and the reason being i don't know
probably because now there's like 16 of
them right the numbers have dwindled
600 of the other right right right
uh only one was like i'll do it i'll go
jedidiah oh my god he's i got this
with the lord on my back i'll be able to
figure it out
so obviously you can't advance with one
person so he actually then asked for
volunteers to ride uh 200 miles to fort
benton and again only one guy
volunteered is jeddah
i'll do it
uh so ashley gets a french-canadian
trapper named baptiste to go with
jedidiah yeah okay what's uh what's up
we're just going to go find a spot for
him
hello i am part of this story now so
wait uh the idea is we go together where
we're going uh-huh we go to the fort
you're french too
yes well
i always thought you were from here
that's the only accent i do so but you
could just be the guy who speaks regular
yeah you've chosen the same
guy i guess they matter you
so
uh so they they head off on two horses
they're going at night as to not be
tracked perfect
because there's bands of of the locals
trying to kill him sure no the night
pitch would work great with me we're
worried about the 600 guys getting us so
we'll go when it's darkest
so one night they came across three
warriors asleep by a campfire and they
killed them as they slept and took their
horses right sure as you're supposed to
do it's very brave it feels it feel i
mean it feels like if you're them you've
got to be like you know you've got to
kind of just assume everyone's going to
try to kill you everyone's going to try
to kill you at this point yeah what is
the plan yeah we just slit the swords
and take the horses you're from france
yeah it still makes no sense but what if
you're here when i'm around you i would
if i did quite insulting to be honest i
would rather you be a centiccu
instead of pretending to be me as well
it's confusing
but when i talk like myself i sound
[ __ ] dumb oh my god just use your
real voice that's why i'm talking like
this much better yes okay yes we should
change your name too the whole your
whole thing is dog [ __ ] francois
hey
so
um
now when they killed the warriors
jedediah was pretty upset because
baptiste took their scalps and he was
like okay that's disrespectful that's
that's not
just thinking about it from a
it's weird yes for sure perfect look
what i got
this is great now we've got these two uh
so eventually where's your head bag what
where's your bag for their heads oh i
don't have a bag for heads i'm actually
not into that like that's not our thing
that's actually a native american
practice and they probably do it they're
probably doing it for centuries and so
it's just my accent i figured that you
it's just like one of my clients accent
the whole thing is we are doing
different uh
cultures now so i just i said yes okay
no it's it's it's am i supposed to just
sit here and just french fries and look
for ranch dipping sauce the whole time
and be like you huh what the [ __ ] study
means it means you're pacific huh it's
disgusting huh
no you're you're just [ __ ] up you're
out of your [ __ ] mind like you're not
telling yourself those are mine's the
guys who said that just cut off
he said it's a good joke huh come on
where's your head bag puts our scaps in
there huh no it's it's got the smell
after a while okay i got it just push
them down the front of our pants that's
not okay
so
they eventually make it to fort benton
and
um they get help and whatever the men
get out of it ashley's men get out of
there okay so on his next expedition
jedediah leads a small party to south
dakota
and western wyoming sure
they're
the first known white people to go there
okay
in the black hills in a way by the way
is that that's kind of an advantage in a
way right be the first white guy yeah
because you could because you know the
the they're not sure right what you are
yeah you'd rather go in unsure than
people knowing what a white person yeah
yeah once once the white secrets out
right then it's bad because they they
learn like oh these people can't be
trusted at all and they're murderers
right yes
um so in the black hills a grizzly bear
surprised
jedediah holy [ __ ] it came out of you're
here or did i i'm not your god i'm gone
okay yep they come out of a the bear
comes out of a thicket like just
springs out of the
and jedediah is on his horse and he gets
knocked off his horse rita ham not it
and
the bear grabs jedediah by the head oh
my lord not okay and jedediah fights
back
and and beats the bear off until it
gives up and
runs off jesus christ he beats a bear up
well i mean he got the worst of it he go
he beat the bear off of him he beat the
bear off difference okay but jedediah is
a mess okay see i mean it i guess it
doesn't it takes very little bear
contact to be broken there's like one
swat yeah just like i mean if they grab
your head yeah yeah they grab your head
that i mean they're not grabbing it
right now you're taking a volleyball the
bear's not grabbing them being like i'm
just trying to get you with the palms
it's like now put your hands on my paws
it's called stage combat
so several of his ribs are broken and
his scalp has been ripped off to the
bone hey i'm still here i'll come back
one of his ears is just dangling from
the side of his head nearly torn off
okay sure
so the other guys he's with they're
pretty horrified like it doesn't look
great right it's hard and there's no
mirror it's hard there's no mirror how
bad is it it could be better it's you're
a lot of your head is off a lot of my
ear hurts yeah well the ears not really
there most of the side of the ear is bad
and pain wise yeah it's it looks more
like an e-ring right now because the way
it's hanging so kind of cool no okay
yeah it's not
woozy over here yeah you should be
because there's your hands i don't even
have the choice to lay down but now i'm
laying down you should definitely lay
down i would late yeah sleepy
so they all think he's going to die
because he's a head open guy sure and
they hide jedediah asks him he goes can
you guys give me some water
and then he talks very calmly
and uh he talks to a
fellow trapper's buddy j james kleiman
he talks him through
cutting away the blood-soaked hair okay
you know what i need to trim right now
you could
sure if you could just get some of the
well it just feels like with my head off
i think that my hair sticks out i mean
it doesn't look great aesthetically i
think we just i but i just feel like i
feel i feel like an idiot i hate that i
wouldn't worry about that it's really
this is a good time for a cut okay we'll
just take a trip take that like a half
inch that's all sure sure
and then they get
he gets a needle and thread from his
saddle bag who
the butt jedediah okay what he's up i'll
do it
and he he talks
climbing through sewing his scalp back
into place
oh i'm not eating pizza
i just
ugh
and climb and he's sewing his ear back
on which climate doesn't even believe he
can do but he get it i was like you
really got to try to put the air back on
because that that thing's hanging and
it's really
and then he does it he finishes and it's
all kind of sewn back into place not not
like a surgeon would do it but more like
a random guy like if you if you went to
a
if you went to a truck stopper like if
somebody stole my head back i put my ear
on yeah that's more like it's more like
a right go to a payless so it's pretty
haphazard
and when it's over he takes how do i
look
ready for my close-up mister ow i ripped
it off by accident
and when it's over jenna takes it he
takes a long drink of water and then he
gets on his horse what
buddy do you want to take the night and
they head back to their camp in the
hills he's like let's go
let's go boys i'm good i'm ready to go
oh god damn now the guys he's with
they're like he's
we don't think he's like placating him
they're like sure yeah this is all good
sure
one last big ride buddy you look great
you're fine
so they go the rocking of the horse's
hooves is not feeling great
so they go off to get help a bunch of
them and the two choppers stay with
jedediah
and they help him heal for a few days
until they get surprised by a
band of native
the native's like one of them is dead
this is easy
and somehow jedediah when they get
attacked he manages to hide in some
bushes oh good for the wound
i fell in some dirt
and the and the
the native american they take everything
everything that's there in the camp they
grab it all and sure
only thing he's left with um
is a rifle
knife flint in his bible now the other
the other trapper's dead they're dead
okay so he has he's alone again with his
bible
and a gun and a bible yeah very uh
compromising wounds yeah okay
so he opens it reads his bible he opens
what his scalp oh sorry the bible sorry
this is a good time to read your bible
yeah for sure
what are some words of wisdom for this
moment focusing my eyes is tough
uh he read quote he is chastened also
with pain upon his bed and the multiple
multitude of his bones and strong pain
yes
his soul draweth near to the grave
and his life to the destroyers his flesh
shall be fresher than a child he shall
return to the days of his youth he shall
pray unto god and he will be favorable
unto him so he's like basically if i
pray hard enough i'm going to live he's
like i got this okay
so the next morning he is in
incredible pain because his member's
head got his
scalp got ripped off still his head
still hurts when the bear rips
off yeah and his buddy stitched it on
kindness and uh
he can't walk so he drags himself over
to the river because he remembers
that they put beaver traps there and
that and the don't fall in them bud
the american indians did not find the
beaver trap so okay he goes over that he
finds one beaver in a beaver trap or a
beaver
and he cooks it and he eats it oh
and on the third day
he managed to shoot a buck wow and he
ate the meat until it goes bad jesus now
he couldn't clean her dresses wounds
and obviously that means infections are
big because you're out sure and if
you've ever had your scalp ripped off
and then sewed it back together and
you're out in the woods i just imagine
it's yeah i would i i mean in today's
day and age this gentleman would be on
antibiotics yes that's right
look it out for those infections yeah uh
so he reads from his bible and i wish
there was a section in here about what
to do with the sutures
[Music]
uh
so he's a lot he's he's kicking him like
that three days go by and then the other
guys come back with a party of trappers
that they come across
and they feed him and they dress his
wounds and then they head they head down
the bighorn river
to yellowstone right these guys have
boats sure
now a crow had told them of a place
excuse me a crow had told them not a not
an actual crow a native american okay uh
of the of the people okay different
i told them yeah they're not talking to
crows yet well listen i've talked to a
crow i know you have a raven does my
taxes
and uh he tells them that there's a
place
nearby that's just got tons of beaver
okay so
uh-huh aaron grow up yeah this is jesus
so this place has a lot of [ __ ] wait
hold on
so he's now he's now okay and they like
he's not clearly not infected to the
point where and it's sewed back together
he doesn't look great does he want to
take a little like a little time no he's
a he's a truck jumping in his bones man
oh no i know it's in his mommy
all right he's still thinking um
yeah so
his his
it's like tilted sort of weird sure and
his one of his eyes is kind of squinting
the way they sewed it together he's
basically got a toupee but his scalp
yeah and for the rest of his life he has
a big comb over situation going on well
i mean he became like his look
well for sure well i don't know if
that's necessarily for him
his gimmick is sort of everyone knew him
by that yeah no because he was attacked
and mauled by a bear yeah so it's not
like he was like you know what i'm going
for a new hairstyle he was like you know
my scalp provides me with little
so i guess what i'll do is just put it
all in one area
so he's a deformed area he's a squint he
has the long ho
long longer ones wispy long ones
nobody's doing it long to one side like
that no that's a good look we've
reserved that for
undertakers in films
so they end up spending the winter at a
crow village
and they would join the crow on hunts
and sure um
jidai estimated they killed over a
thousand buffalo that year wow which is
totally unnecessary well yeah from where
yeah like if you're bragging about that
someone should be like that's actually
like really messed up over the top yeah
yeah
we'll show them
so um so in the spring the men learned
of a crow route across the continental
divide over the south pass in wyoming
okay
um so they they took that what are they
are they still trying to what are they
going for now he's he's still trying to
get
to places where no one's been okay
that's just sort of explore okay
um
this the south pass route they didn't
find it but they sort of rediscovered it
and then tons of people would end up
using that route that sounds like the
world immigrants yeah
so in the summer of 1826 um they go to
rendezvous
and it was a place well i'll tell ya
so
rendezvous is an annual
fur trading
fur con for it's a fur con they go to
fur con it's 100 for a con that's what
it is it's fur con okay okay so
oh yeah
so it happened once i can't believe what
you're doing with pelts this year you
keep bringing vent in the whale over
here scratch
thank you
unbelievable yeah i also got coffee and
look at what this guy's done he's made a
bowl out of teeth yeah no he's that guy
he's
whoo he's crazy keep your lanyards on
you boys that guy lost his mind he's out
of his [ __ ] mind i can hear you well
okay no i i i forgot i was talking to
you when i said that um
anyway you're you're out of your
own a tooth hat no no
yeah i know are those
what animal are the teeth humans okay
that's what i was worried about
relatives okay every one of these teeth
is from someone i've met we should not
do that
have do you have any
friends people that you
how long have you been
out
this here is an ashtray made out of my
uncle's teeth i have to go all right
so where are we headed
it's i'm gonna not
let me go to the bathroom same here nope
yeah different one you've got one or two
best friend
so here's what rendezvous is all the all
the trappers come together the traders
the trappers
they buy furs they sell whiskey e3 but
for beavers it's supplies right it's
it's a drunken crazy totally there's
hookups it sounds like one of the worst
places to ever go i want to go there oh
the smell so travis take that sturgis
trappers could go and sell beaver pelts
and then they wouldn't have to go to st
louis to sell them right right so they
sell them for last but the trip isn't
happening so it's a it's a wash um
whiskey tobacco coffee all very
expensive everything's expensive this is
i mean
because it's where it is it's in the
middle of [ __ ] yeah it's fur con
other supply uh other supplies trappers
would use they get marked up 200 it's
just
starting to lose the threat on why
people are going a little bit well
because they can sell i mean basically
it's just a [ __ ] party right it's a
it's a con right you get to go hang out
with your bros talk business talk beaver
business right and get hammered um they
spent a whole season's earnings on
whiskey and women in good times and just
bad thing to do like the more i hear
about it you want to avoid fur con
so well i lost my years wealth
at first time i hope i'm happy but i got
shit-faced and some coffee all the
memories i almost had
a a really good trapper would go there
with 300 300 or 400 pelts after a season
um in 1825 jedediah rolled in was 668.
damn
and then he he formed a partnership with
uh two trappers one was william sublette
where's the other one uh i don't know i
don't know i'm the one who comes up in
the future with the ideas that when you
don't want to break your lease someone
moves in for you yes yeah okay i don't
know what that means it should be named
after me it's called the william
sublette
huh my name is anzalese you pay me
nobody's the wiser
um they end up buying out william
ashley's share
of his trapping operation for 16 000 now
jesus they didn't they didn't
buy it all but they like they were going
to pay them off over a couple years
it's a sort of
it's an acquisition yeah so the
partnership goes great the first year um
his partners
go north or in the area and jedediah is
is going to go south sure so that's like
they're like fan out we'll get a bunch
of beaver pelts and come back to
rendezvous next year okay
now sublet's party goes north
and there they quickly learn horses
cannot make it
through the frozen plains on the little
bit of vegetation that's around okay
great lesson so those horses don't make
it okay
eaten okay great they ate the horses
what else are you gonna do with how was
the mission well i'll tell you i don't
feel like eating horse for a while
it's a nightmare terrible absolute hell
on earth so they end up walking and
barely surviving they had a dog which
eventually they killed and ate because
well well
yeah at some point some nights they had
to just keep walking to a freud avoid
freezing to death so keep their
temperatures if you've ever been in that
area of the country i cannot explain how
[ __ ] cold it is when there's a
[ __ ] cold air blowing down from
canada it is yeah um so they just had to
keep walking they couldn't sleep yep
luckily they come across some native
americans who save them and give them
shelter and food for the winter once
again
too nice yep you'll uh yeah you won't
regret this gonna come back to haunt you
the whole helping people out thing trust
me you can trust us forever
so meanwhile jedediah is exploring the
shoreline of great salt lake okay
and he would always name places ignoring
that they might already have names yes
davey was uh white
[Laughter]
he named a river adams river for
president john quincy adams
although today it's the virgin river
which is named after one of his
companions thomas virgin someday i want
to have sex but only one that's right
i'm drowning you have to die
okay
this is my luckily
if you had been [ __ ] you'd be all
right
well i guess he's not going to say
anything cause he's dead
anywho are there any beavers
uh there are no beavers here not in the
salt lake area
in mid-september they're almost out of
dried meat that's what they're surviving
on okay
so one day as uh they're setting up camp
they notice over a dozen paiutes are
watching them okay again another another
group of indian local people
they're watching them and um jedediah
walks out alone to invite one of them
into camp okay
and one pipe man comes and he's holding
a rabbit out which
who is the the paiute okay and he's like
that means yeah coming as friends right
right
and jedi accepted accepts it and he
speaks very kindly with them and soon
other people come down and start
approaching would they have like an ear
horn all like hey we're here to be
friendly a lot of rabbits i don't know
if i need all quite all of these
this is over 30 rabbits which is
fantastic
no more rabbits though can i i too many
it is a rabbit you keep thank you so
much literally
can't do enough with these i'm going to
start handing them back to you if you
we're really trying to get rid of these
yes so okay a lot so we just want to get
rid of it all right great bring them
down here's another four holy [ __ ]
that's a is that a wheelbarrow yes
no
uh they bring in the truck oh no back it
up
jedediah gives them gifts in return a
rubber and a razor knives gunpowder
some lead balls that kind of business
these are my littles
i was not expecting that uh yeah they're
big it wasn't a good joke
gotcha
so they stayed for a while okay
and uh
they trade iron for produce corn and
pumpkin so the
these people are giving them food and in
return they're getting iron and [ __ ] to
make weapons and weapons yeah
um but the pioneers could not tell them
much about going south
um there's a desert down there and they
don't know much because they've never
been like hey let's walk through that
[ __ ] desert we're good here with the
food we got a bunch of rabbits
so after a while jedidiah's group goes
south it's hot it's super [ __ ] hot
the men the horses are having a really
hard time great so now they're in a part
of zion national park okay which is
[ __ ] the best place in america
jediah said he quote learned what it was
to do without food so and this is the
bible man's way of saying i'm dying
holy [ __ ] i'm hungry
there's almost no game there's hardly
any fresh water uh it's taken two days
to get from one water hole to the next
and then when they reach the colorado
river the horses are dying okay
and
they end up eating the horses sure yeah
i figured the horses were yeah they're
not gonna yeah
uh the river water is muddy so it wasn't
yeah good
water they grainy
when uh they moved on over half the
horses
are dead so a lot of the men are now on
foot
and then they enter the mojave desert oh
and then i'm sorry and then they enter
them right so they're like i feel like
it's about to cool off a little bit
son of a [ __ ] what about the worst part
of this no
let's head into the worst part now
okay
now they get to what is like around
needles california now okay and they
run across the mojave indians okay
and they give them shelter
for 15 days and let them recuperate
because they're a [ __ ] mess
and they feed them melons and vegetables
from their garden
and they tell make note we should come
back and ruin this
let's put a pin in this
they tell jedidiah that there is an old
indian trail across the desert that goes
from the spanish missions in california
to here okay
and so he's like well can you take me
and so two guys i'd like to discover it
if you could show it to me
could you show me where that is so i can
discover it for everyone i would like to
name this trail yes i'm after things yes
please uh so these two guides
know the way because they had fled from
the mission san gabriel i just took them
back in my head this dude is just after
money it's just yeah he wants cash
so for 15 days they try to follow the
mojave river but it keeps disappearing
because it's a river in the desert so it
just vanishes all right
well that was uh takes another break
here for a while the river is again dirt
uh so jedi he tried to name the mojave
river the uh in constant river but it
never stuck yeah it's a great name yeah
it's really inconstant what about mojave
no where it feels made up oh well it's
actually the name of the people and the
land we it's mostly river we'll call it
great it's not those are all better
we'll charge five dollars to look at it
great
perfect we're good people money
so it's really hot they're [ __ ]
thirsty as [ __ ] but they they make it to
california following this trail
and
he's the they're the first white men to
make this overland southwest crossing
the mojave route yeah they did it
so independently
it's remarkable
the spirit of the first white guy to
follow a couple of
non-white guys yeah yeah the first guy
who needed to be melon fueled
i'm the first man who needs a lot of
suntan lotion to go this way
i did it all by myself except for when
they fully carried me and filled me with
melon for a fortnight
other than that i did it all and they
discovered it already what an amazing
feat when i did this thing where people
had to feed me melons for 15 days how
many people to thank mainly me
[Laughter]
so uh now they're in the san bernardino
valleys it's like paradise compared to
where they've been there sheep there's
cattle horses grazing green green
streams or we call bakersfield or
victorville today
so the half star of men meet some friars
at
a mission ranch and they escort them to
mission san gabriel okay
it's about nine miles east of downtown
los angeles
now i think i want to act
all of a sudden i feel like pretending a
bit is that strange hello i'm here to
make films uh i'd just like to look at
the camera and say things like we'll be
right back
um so there's a padre in charge of
everything father joseph and he allows
jedidiah's jedi's men to eat and rest
there
and then in response to that jetted i
named mountains after him uh-huh sure
whatever
it's like thank you for the biscuits
yeah uh if you look over there that
one's named i'm gonna father joe do that
next time i'm at the store be like and
instead of paying you that mcdonald's is
now kathy's vote okay thank you so much
i can't give you money but that
mcdonald's is yours just don't even
worry about it
so california is spanish territory right
so
that means jedediah and his party are
there illegally right
and
he's taken because of that when the
whites were illegal in california it's
just [ __ ] amazing
topsy-turvy so he is then because of
this taken to the governor in san jose
okay governor wants to see him okay
san jose
what about petersburg
[Applause]
my friend
i i've renamed your city it's now jeff
it's now jedediah
um so the spanish colonizers they know
nothing about trapping beavers and in a
report written for the governor
they called jedediah a fisherman because
that was the closest thing that they
understand he was like no the wet
animals we're looking for wet wet
animals catch his furry fish sir he's
rarely kissing it's a it's a wet it's a
it's a wet animal a wet fish
it's a hammer tailed fish tree muncher
not a fish it is a fish i'm getting
extreme confirmation this is a fish it's
not a fig big teeth big teeth fish got
got tree teeth treating a hammer tape
he's got three teeth he's got a hammer
tail and he's a fish but he's into trees
not a fish he's definitely a furry yes
animal
fish no dish almost okay
he is
a dog
okay are we close wet dog he's a wet
puppy yeah with a hammer tail oh he's
got it
we know those
so
uh
so the governor
he's like what the what the [ __ ] is this
guy he's suspicious
and then and now they're like these guys
are spies
okay good so they're [ __ ] spies
they're they're here spying for whatever
uh
england or france right so jedi i can't
convince him that he was quote only a
hunter and that dire necessity had
driven me here he can't commit some of
that right
so he's put under house arrest and
for some reason they put him in house
arrest in san diego but give me that
they are moving around the state foreign
no it's amazing
and he's and he is easier to get around
the state then do not i know it's really
crazy that bummer okay he's under arrest
and take him i guess to san diego and
they took what they called a light rail
it's really nice there the weather is
really just sort of 75 all the time oh
it's perfect beautiful views yeah have
you seen simon and simon
yes yeah it's like that it's a if so if
if you want to be a detective it's a
good place to be great yeah and that's
uh yes i think um so they're there for
six weeks under
under
lock and key sure and then there's
there's three american merchant ships
that are anchored in the bay and they
and they vouch for him for some reason i
don't know what happened there but
they're like no he's a good guy
without knowing they must have gone and
talked to him or something or found out
about him so sure
so jedediah and his men are then
released
because of the word these guys give
that's crazy on the condition that they
leave california okay and they have to
leave the same way they came what that's
some [ __ ] that's like that's like
where you're just being like vindictive
and um
you must go back through hell
to get home
um but he's also like there's no way i'm
going through the [ __ ] mojave again
absolutely not
or really even uh leave california right
it's pretty big so he
he wants to try instead an unexplored
route because that's his whole gym right
he's all about that
so he heads north and he goes across the
hatchery mountains and he goes into the
san joaquin valley okay which is rivers
and very nice and um they go north and
they're fishing and trapping in monterey
and the san francisco bay so they're
kind of going all over and they're
having a little california event yeah
they're doing a little thing and then
they get to the american river which is
near sacramento okay they're poor their
horses now
are packing over 1500 pounds oh my god
beaver pelts
so they're scoring
it's amazing that the that the spanish
in charge didn't know what beavers were
didn't quite understand what they were
talking about there are beavers
yeah and and they rest
and then in may 1927 horses must be
exhausted
they go east over the sierra nevada
mountains okay
and
five horses die in the snow because it's
snowing heavily sure
so they have to retreat seven miles 75
miles back to the stanislaus river okay
and
jedediah then takes two men
names evans and gobel and
they he tries to cross with them just
again
and he's going to return supplies he's
like you guys stay here i'll go get
supplies so we can make the journey sure
and he says at four months i'll be back
in four months what i i don't know what
that's just life back then but it's a
nightmare i know it's just how it worked
can you hang on for four months if i
know we're dying do you have four months
left in the tank if if i don't come back
in four months go ahead and i guess just
die after four months no it's your turn
to leave and try to yeah yeah yeah so
wait
wait for a pin and dying for four months
and then let's decide
so he leaves behind eleven guys now they
build log cabins and just start trapping
where they are right in stanislaus
but spanish authorities at this point no
they're like hey
you didn't go back through the mojave at
all yeah that's not what we said now
they've heard jedi has violated the his
agreement to leave which he has go yeah
and um and that he's still in california
so these soldiers come to the camp but
jedediah is gone right so they're like
what do we do
they
they talk to the men they believe the
men are going to leave
in when they get a chance after winter's
over he's he's he's literally coming
right back it'll just be about four
months
and so uh so they let him stay there but
it's a little iffy right yeah okay
so
jedi's party crosses the sierras it
takes him eight days and now they're in
the great basin which is
it's hell greatest we're back to dry
nightmarish okay unbelievable
so they have four uh pack animals they
started with seven sure well that yummy
yummy that's less yep
and crosston like i said it's
[ __ ] hell so one by one as they're
crossing
the great basin the horses start dying
or they're killing them for food one or
the other cool then their water runs out
great
and they're eating the flesh they're
drinking the blood of the horses to stay
alive
you just probably just poke a hole in
one and have like a spigot yeah it's
like the gatorade ads eventually you're
just sweating the red that's right so
you know it's working
uh on june 25th evans collapsed from
thirst and exhausted let's drink his
blood
that's where you're at you know
okay
good news bad news evans is dead good
news we eat tonight and we can finally
get some blood oh my god i'm so thirsty
you know what i could go for it a big
cold club big cold cup of evans oh it'll
be so good oh god i can't evans hang on
but if not we're gonna pound your blood
so fast i'm gonna drink it like it's a
punch bowl oh you know what i might
drink my own actually don't you [ __ ]
dare drink your own blood you selfish
prick i opened my knee
oh god looks
well it's all part of one cycle in you
and once you pass i'll have it too
so after they talked
uh jedidiah and gobble decide to just
leave evans and go on without him oh
come on drink his blood
jedidiah wrote in his diary quote we
could do no good by remaining to die
with him drink his blood
i mean if you're drinking a whole blood
suck out at least suck out an eye at the
very least something take something
three months we're gonna take your balls
for comedy
sorry only for comedy we just said we're
gonna hang it on the back of our hats
like it's on the dash
three months later they come across a
small water hole
and they're like urethra they drink like
fish
yeah like a urethra like
hairy fish yeah hairy fish
jedediah fills a container with water
and he puts a piece of horse meat in it
well that'll keep it
better than cork
well i'm going to put this in here
because i have no idea what in the [ __ ]
i'm doing this is going to be terrible
this is what we call tupperware well he
does that and then he hurries back to
evans
okay so he's like evans jedediah putting
the kettle to his mouth he did not take
it away until he had drank all of the
water of which there was at least four
or five quarts and then asked me why i
had not brought more yeah
yeah so that's it
what was with that dumb horse meat at
the end
have you tried vitamin water it's like
that except i'm i'm trying a horse
yeah it's a nice flavor right it's tangy
but it's nice it's good i like the
chunks it's like boba yeah can you jog
now or what's your deal bring more water
to me a couple yeah we're gonna run
you're gonna have to run to the wall
there's water there but you gotta run
for it
same way you can having one of my lazy
days yeah well it's run time is it
sunday because it sure feels like it's a
cattle prod we're about to use it guys
i'm just so tired yeah here we go i just
feel like channel surfing do you ever
watch bar rescue yes this show's great i
love it the host seems like a right-wing
lunatic yeah i mean there's that
so evan survives and they move on
together they're now they can now see
the great salt lake they're the first
men uh white men to cross the great
basin over a thousand miles mostly on
man the first and men and who were white
and i would imagine maybe the first men
because i think most native americans be
like why the [ __ ] would you walk that
way because we're looking for money
dummy we're [ __ ]
uh you see we're motivated by making
money we're like a nightmare for this
place
and we're not gonna rest until it's all
[ __ ] gone hello capitalism's here
we're gonna ruin this knock knock may we
come in we're already in
welcome to the beaver apocalypse did you
like having them around that's over
let's do that with everything
so on july 3rd this could be a mall
on july 3rd they stumble into bear lake
which is where
every year is held
rendezvous oh no so they roll in in the
middle of rendezvous do they don't know
they're going to rendezvous i i think
they didn't they probably didn't know
the timing of it all but they they
rolled in when [ __ ] trap con is going
on have they so they've discovered
something but now they're just randomly
at the at trap cop they're back where
they started they're they're at foreign
back where they started okay
um it's yeah it's roundabout 1827.
everyone just cannot believe
because they thought they were dead they
haven't seen him in so long we thought
you guys were all dead we kind of were
they shoot a small cannon to celebrate
that they're back but the bigger one
they had also been firing off the cannon
all rendezvous so it's kind of right not
really yeah right
it's like the guy who's like you got to
do a shot to celebrate so he's done 15
already oh my god dude gotta do another
run to baby cannon
now jedi's partners who had gone north
in in the area they did well and so they
had a bunch of beaver pelts he didn't he
i don't think he had any i mean the
other guys he's like we we ate them the
other guys remember the guys he left
four months the other guys
right
so they pay
they use those other beaver belts and
they pay their debt to william ashley
and he advances them supplies for the
next year so their business is making
money okay
but jedi is like i gotta get back to my
dudes yeah stanislaus river and bring
him supplies
so
before he leaves he writes a note to
william clark the famous explorer sure
and the superintendent who's now the
superintendent of indian affairs for the
upper missouri and mississippi rivers so
clark scott for the white man affairs
yes white man and
he said the pious and mojaves were quote
extremely poor
and the lowest intermediate link between
man and the brute creation
and in the mental scale lower than i
have yet seen extra extra white man's
here officially the white man's
officially arrived so so the first so
the the people who saved his life the
people who say it's it's what we call
the whiting
it's how the white works thank you so
much i'll never forget you now you're
technically an animal to me and i can do
whatever i want hello
i mean they saved his [ __ ] life they
fed him for 15 days they gave him
shelter and the price did their own
thing to save them and he's just like
man they're [ __ ] [ __ ] all stupid
they're dumb
[ __ ] dumbass
you know what's smart as a dude who
walks through the desert
if i'd known you needed two weeks worth
of melon i'd have brought it i'd have
brought it
so he heads back out he he takes 18 men
he takes two uh and they and they
brought two of their native american
wives so two guys in that group bring
their
wives okay
slaves i don't know what that is like
i i don't know how the marrying worked
back then right yeah probably
yeah not great probably well yeah
but i mean we don't know but yeah again
it's like a guess it's it's just when
there's a track record you can kind of
speculate
so he he retraces the same path he goes
to the same villages uh he's still
heading to the colorado river again i
get lost when i look for my car
sometimes yeah i cannot imagine the idea
of imagining being like yeah this is
right too
you know the confidence i think i just i
think i went through this it was a
purple e4 i think what i uh it was
which one's an alligator and then some
guy in another car saves you for four
days oh well yeah yeah right
hey god for your subaru you need more
iced tea do you need more teva iced tea
so here's some more chex mix if you need
it i'm so nourished
he uh
he gets to the mojave
this is where most of us die
right well so this is where yeah so he
gets the mojave and
they build rafts to cross to get the
supplies across the colorado river okay
and um
as jed so he he
i guess they have two rafts or maybe
he's taking a raft over and then they're
gonna bring it back and bring the rest
of the supplies sure i'm not sure which
way
um this works but he gets to the other
side of the river jedediah does right
okay
and um
as he as he just reaches it
mojave warriors oh no
come from behind and kill the guys who
are waiting to cross oh wow so all of a
sudden it's just like a slaughter i
think i'll stay on this side
it seems like that side's getting a
little precarious
they kill 10 men he's got 18. they kill
and they take the two native american
women
and he's just all he can do with his
guys is just watch it happen across the
river and then he
runs they run for it yeah okay
new plan
go
um and so they they hide
okay and they make spear they make
spears from branches and they tie knives
to the end of the poles because i guess
they don't have guns they must have been
with the other guys
i don't know so
you guys hold on to everything
and i'm gonna shoot over there make
contact then i'll come back then we'll
start
kind of bailing the bucket over that
direction so once i get over there you
guys will have it all
then i'll start coming back yeah great
good question right all right see
anything that could go wrong stay in a
bit bye
so
they fight with the mojave's um
jedediah's man managed to kill
two of them and then they retreat okay
only one of jedidized men are are
wounded okay so they eventually wait and
and then they slip away into the desert
but they have no supplies now right and
they're on foot right
so they have i guess they do they have
five rifles some bullets and um some
dried meat yum
now there is one wounded guy he needs
help walking okay they don't have guides
um so they have to rely on his memory to
get through the desert sure so odds of
them living or
that's not great sure
but they come across
another band of native americans who
trade
them horses okay so they must have
traded i assumed the rifles yeah okay
summer's at its peak right it's [ __ ]
or we could dance for you
yeah okay just the guns okay it's august
in the mojave desert yeah it's the hell
it's nice
and jedi keeps losing the trail as we
know what happened before
but somehow he gets them to san gabriel
in late august
jesus
and there they recover a bit and then
jed and i uh at jedi heads north to see
the [ __ ] guys at the stanislaus
he arrives two days before the
four-month deadline wow he's like what's
up hey
i told you four months didn't i
who's good with time could have been
earlier had some snags hit a snag or two
so
the men are super excited to see them
until they find out that half his party
have been killed and all the supplies
are gone oh the whole reason he came so
sorry sorry i should start with this
things are as dire as when i left no but
you brought you came back i had all kind
of stuff i had a ton of oh well yeah
let's get it well what i did was i left
it with a bunch of my men our men men
um you guys look good by the way thank
you what are you guys doing we have been
working out it looks good it looks good
when we started the place looks good too
yeah um
we're losing a lot of weight i can see
so
um so i left it all on one what was i
saying oh it left it all on one side of
the river can we get that yes and uh
crossed the river okay then was about to
go back on the big old you left the
supplies back on the other side of the
river the well i'm trying to think which
side you're talking about the side you
left the supplies were on that side so
you didn't bring them with you i went on
the other side of the river without them
about to go back and grab them all yeah
well you should have brought them first
i was about to uh and then um i'm trying
what happened next oh they murdered most
of the guys they took all the stuff they
yeah
i don't remember their names but they
were you know
they were
natives native of natives they were you
know what i mean they are talking about
the mojave yes that's it they were the
guys who gave us the melons and let us
hang out with them for like 15 days yeah
well i'll tell you what they have a bug
up their ass now and i don't i'll tell
you that is one thing i just you can't
trust them i mean that's how i feel this
you just can't trust i mean we're the
straight shooters oh clearly we're the
white man
so clearly nothing
it's not like because when we came
through they were our friends they were
mountain people and then they
don't friends
it's almost as if white people did
something in between when you came and
when they killed let me think because i
want to get this right other white guys
probably came to don't want to
irrationally blame them somebody did
something bad i'm trying to think
because i should know it's just nothing
is ringing
which i think they
now i'm pretty sure they were just being
jerk-offs the more i think about it they
just
yeah they've lost their cool not cool
again they didn't have a melon on them
so this was a totally
different generation it's just different
they've lost the plot i'm more worried
about the fact that we have no supplies
now because you went away for four
months and i [ __ ] off almost four
months but here's the good news
i pretty much know the way now so that's
good it's gonna be hell
on earth so
but um okay
so yeah so um you're not good at this
you guys have any food
famished i would i really could eat when
you eat bob i would love to get a piece
of him if there's any of him left i'll
eat a toe i'll eat a dick i don't even
give a [ __ ] anymore i don't want to hear
that all right
well good to get the band back together
so here's the good news
the trappers now because they've been
their performance they have a shitload
of beaver pelts okay
so they head to mission san jose to
trade the beaver pelts for supplies sure
now here's the problem with san jose
uh-huh that's where the governor is and
he doesn't lie and there's been an
agreement he's been told to leave so
he's immediately arrested as he goes
there yes oh god okay and taken to
monterey and put in jail okay
he tries to explain he's like this is
what happened i'm dying do you
understand that i'm dying can somebody
understand that i'm dying he's like this
was all to leave forever the whole plan
was to leave yeah trying to uh but they
didn't speak they didn't speak english
and he doesn't speak spanish right
so they have no idea what he's talking
about
um now fortunately
while again while he was in jail he
became friends with a different american
chip captain again this happens again
sure of course
and that guy what are you in for
that guy and four other americans
posed a 30 dollar bond for his release
how do you i don't understand charming
are you to get strangers to pay a thirty
thousand dollars
can't understand what's happening here
damn now he can leave on two conditions
okay
first he has to sell the furs okay to
the ship's captain at a very low price
okay
so this guy's going to get his money
back and more right i assume yeah second
he has to leave california going the way
he came now this time we want you to
really go the way you came we don't
think you did that before
get out of here
they were very close i want you to walk
backwards like that guy from a couple
episodes ago
they're very clear they're like
that's it this is your last [ __ ]
chance no more chance
that's it
leave don't come back so he's like okay
i agree and they free him
he doesn't leave california i love it
he goes to san francisco where his men
are and he rejoins them hey
party all right
and then they head back down to the
stanislaus river now they have horses
and supplies
and in january 1828 they head into the
mountains of northern california there's
lots of game
they trap more furs
at one point several of bears several
bears attack the party at once okay and
jetta died dives into a stream to get
away from him oh my god
are you mad at seeing a bear again i've
done this before it's not good no i
don't like bears
oh my god so
um when they cross the sacramento river
by the way i mean the idea that you're
like oh safety in the river they're like
we're also down here eat from here we
eat out of the river all the time the
river is great
so they fear water they don't oh god
that's not good
so when they cross the sacramento river
jedi names it the buena ventura which
obviously doesn't stick right he's
always naming stuff right no one's right
okay buddy yeah that's
in june uh they enter oregon so they're
going north you mean jeddah dyersville
uh yes
now they traded with the uh kel watson
people
jedi was very friendly with most
most native americans but he
but then a total dick in his journal
descriptions right when he tells other
people about them when he writes about
them he's well that's like most people's
diary
he said they were such a good friend of
mine oh god bob is such a jerk
so sick of bob
uh he said they were impoverished
because they were lazy and had quote a
deficiency of genius inferior to the
beaver they just want everything given
to them
what it is is that they're not trying to
profit off everything and so he thinks
they're [ __ ] dumb right
he's the dumb one they're living with
nature you can sell this rock you fools
he wrote derisively by the way
take the path of the white men it ends
so good it's so good soon
he wrote derisively that many quote live
without anything in the shape of a house
and rise from their bed of earth in the
morning like the animals around them and
rove about in search of food he said
they were degrading ignorant literally
what everyone does every day well also
one you wake up and you're like i need
food yeah they well if you've been
living that way forever then why would
you you're like this is fine you don't
have a house you need to have bedrooms
a house
yeah um
so yeah so he he's disgusted they lived
very simply when god had given them all
this [ __ ] to sell you can make houses
and sell them
make money own things you can put a
fence around the lake you own the lake
hi lake
on july 14th jedediah and two men went
out scouting while they were gone the
kalasat came to the camp and there was
an argument over an axe being stolen
sure it ended with the kelsat killing
every trapper except for one guy named
arthur black
a black runs into the woods
after he'd been stabbed several times
and he just keeps moving for four days
completely naked and bleeding until a
friendly group of american indians found
him and brought him to a hudson bay
outpost in vancouver oh my god four days
or days bleeding running naked i mean
come on
so when jed and i come back to the camp
um and hello okay we're back are the
pancakes ready
the kawasaki shot at them and they
managed to escape but they left all the
furs and supplies behind okay
so again
a friendly group of locals helped
guiding them north
so they arrive at florida this is los
angeles no no no no
they arrive at fort vancouver two days
after naked and bleeding arthur black
arrived hey
buddy what's up
i calmly walked away from the scene
fully clothed
and not stabbed oh i've been here for a
few days let me guess you guys panicked
or something it's good here
so the head of hudson's bay operations
offers to help jedediah he went back
with three of his men
22 hudson bay men and 14 native
americans to get their stuff back from
the kawasaki okay so and then they
entered negotiations and it took him
like when your dad drives you over to
like get something back it's kind of
like
hey that's that kid timmy took that ball
from you yeah yeah we're gonna go back
over there and you're gonna you're gonna
tell timmy what's up you're gonna get
the ball back you talk to his parents
you say that's my ball uh yeah you're
gonna get the ball back how i get
respect yeah yeah you're totally gonna
get respect you respect me i'm gonna sit
in the car you go ahead and go up to the
front door and just take care of this
thanks daddy yeah yeah
okay get out of the car okay
we haven't driven there yet so you want
me to walk while you follow me
yeah get that car and walk i'm gonna
drive behind your chip it's not a power
trip man i'm trying to teach you how to
be a man okay
take your shirt off okay what dad just
trust me take your shirt off okay you
put some oil put some oil on your face
well i don't have it what is that crisco
yeah well whatever you can it's the same
kind of oil it's gonna throw it on your
face there's a lot of it and then cut
your chest why wait what the [ __ ] is
going on dad
so um
they negotiate with the colors up for
weeks
weeks they're threatening violence and
yeah weeks and uh hey it's like the
infrastructure package
eventually the cable set returned
hundreds of beaver belts otter skins
some horses rifles traps
the hudson bay leader buys he buys the
furs and jedediah in return tells him
everything that he's learned about
california in the west okay they love me
there bring me up if you want oh that
i'm such a
lovely love me
so he ends up making about 2 400 from
that jesus whole situation
and they head out and arrive back in
time back in time what year is this
my god we've done it again i told you
this river has some special qualities to
it
this is back where it all started look
at my hair it's normal i haven't been
attacked by the bear yet
wait a minute
the hell
so they arrived back in time for the 19
sorry no 18 the rendezvous
what's up guys
hey get the baby cannon
so now jedediah and his partners his
partners have been out trafficking he
remember he made 2 400. yeah so they've
got a nice chunk of change yeah
but
at the same time his two trips have now
cost the lives of 33 men yeah it wasn't
easy
[Applause]
you got to break a few eggs to make
anomaly
in 1830 jedi and his partners sell their
business as they they foresee that that
there's going to be a trading problem
ahead because all the beavers are being
killed
and there's a lot more trappers and
there's less demand so he walks away
jedediah walks away with 18 000. okay
a lot of [ __ ] money it's like a
million okay he's done well oh 500 000
today which is yeah so he's rich
jedediah then goes back to st louis he
buys a farm buys a couple of slaves
oh good slaves awesome slaves learns how
to be a racist perfect um it comes
pretty easy yeah no he's actually got
that down
but it's not the life for him
uh
a year later he's feeling restless i
want to die again i want to get out
there and die and each other almost died
you know it was so great have you ever
watched 33 men die over four years i
killed so many men for money ah
so at this time some friends are like
man we're going on a trip to santa fe
i'm in let's kill these people you gotta
come yes let me leave
yes
santa okay now that's in i believe
spanish territory so william ashley his
old employer gets him a passport okay so
this time he's legally going
and they leave in the spring of 1831 25
wagons 85 men
two of them are jedediah's brothers
and they start running out of water
somewhere between
arkansas and the cimarron rivers okay
great perfect just great to be back out
there nearly dying now
late in may jedediah and the very famous
scout broken hand fitzgerald
go ahead of the rest of the group to
scout for water but then fitzgerald's
horse gets hurt
and he has to return to the wagon train
and jetted eyes like i'm just going to
go on
the head alone
and uh
and don't worry he's never seen again
okie
so
now the wagon train makes it to santa fe
and there they run into some mexican
traders
one
who has jedediah's rifle and pistols
okay and he says we had we bought them
from the comanches okay so so what had
happened was around 20 comanche warriors
were waiting for buffalo at a water hole
and then jedediah strolled in so they
killed him let's just kill him
wow
as he fell he shot and killed one of the
comanches he was
32 years old oh my god he was 30 30
[ __ ] two years old
that is so crazy
i mean you're picturing like a 50 year
old yeah
um
he saw maybe more wilderness than lewis
and clark did but he's not as recognized
his journals were lost in a fire after
his death and in north western
california there's a redwood forest
named after him
he jetta died
[Laughter]
so
this
story was recommended by
dan and julie demundo and it was
researched by
sarah
june
and the sources uh
tragic by paige smith tragic encounters
the people's history of native americans
john mooring men with sand great
explorers of the north american west
jack alder exploring historic california
david weber the californios versus
jedidiah smith and um
barton arbor jedi smith no ordinary
mountain man
he was no ordinary mountain man he was
not he really it was definitely not
ordinary it would be
i bet under that scalp was like
terminator steel
just because god damn just kept going
i just want him he just it's so funny
that he finally made his money he was
like ah turns out not was not my
motivation yeah yeah i just like being
evil
that's what i enjoy
you know i i don't know if you've ever
led a group of guys where most of them
die but it's pretty great
but it's also it's so easy the way that
like our society's mentality is
acquiesced into that sort of thinking
like it's the thinking we're founded
upon yeah so of course you see in
today's society the same thinking i mean
the thinking is just get your [ __ ]
money and [ __ ] everything yeah and
that's really what we're founded upon
it's just there was a lot more resources
and it was just
you know very acceptable to murder
people for possessions or for land or
um or things like that and you know it
you see where it gets you like it's the
same i mean it is just like it's like
you know jeff bezos would be this guy in
this time you know like
or worse worse probably yeah yeah
but there there's a like
these people can go out like they can
hunt all the beavers because it doesn't
destroy everything but right once
there's a bunch of people hunting all
the beavers and all the things well then
everything stops working and grinding to
a hulk because the more people they are
seeking profit
the more trouble that becomes for
natural resources totally but but at
least then they were going for like a
thing that well you know what i mean
like we now will like burn down
things to plant things that will make us
more money versus the things that will
actually
you know say like we just we sacrifice
environment
so carelessly at this point that it's
just like you know i mean it's uh it
feels pretty unsustainable oh really
yeah a little bit yeah i didn't notice
that yeah yeah but um
what a weird taste it's strange but but
it is i mean it's like you know we
we are we are founded upon that
mentality the white white
people came here with this
mentality of we don't give a [ __ ] about
anything other than each other and
making money and money more than that
and then
and again it's resulted in a pretty good
that's been great i'm excited for where
well american number one isn't it no by
far yeah
by far
we're the best at everything yeah name
one thing we didn't do the best exactly
i mean we treat people the only thing
we're not the best at is acknowledging
our bestness yeah but we're not we don't
think we're very humble humble country
americans are very humble country yeah
that's what they always say in europe no
you can't find the americans no you
can't notice americans find one american
who has something good to say about
america good luck to you yeah they just
don't they think it we think it at home
we don't need to put it on
jackets and cars and bumper stickers try
to find one truck in this country that's
100 made a flag you can't though
you can't
wearing an america shirt in america is
like wearing the shirt of the band
you're going to see
[Laughter]
come on
it would be like buying a t-shirt in the
airport and putting it on like look at
this charlotte
all right [ __ ] it okay great attitude
hey everybody that's uh dave signing off
for the dollop i'm gareth another good
time charlie goodbye go carts
in saint louis
i said go cards